синій мартин брати участь вона звучного
експерименту
ще місяць його на 3 травня вид держави 570
євро як шалений базовий дахід на за
лижну кручена проти нього на джині
зазвучали легше де зарубати намаза
є дудакова заруб так з меншу
суму державні допомоги та
проти синього не втрачає бази мати
чоловіки весь проти ти не повний
робочий день в чудово так важливо багатий
олег шакали на закладі але вид того
скільки я за рубляються з великою він з
менше аміду хіт фінсько влада перед
частіше у травні будь йому
роботи зможе ви куну вати для 6 вийти в
брати сповільню дим і
теж моя ж усім було дати оплати це
базовий дахід скорочень багата складаних
схем на ринку брати
думкою політики все до проекту
розділилося а у позиція важа експеримент
недоліки репрезентативних бутікград до
експерименту slide було за промінь це
більше людей різьблених гаузи і тим самим їх
розумів і тп рієнці фрілансерів студентів та
ти хто інше неповний день
студія inci по раку але тебе ж
програма вид крилові можливості для
людей через її допомогу
ближче громадян зможе знайти роботу
обвисло і очевидно ще для зміни системи
соціального забезпечення нам потрібно більше
інформації про різанину веде моделей
несжимаема за раз боровся відкриті ноту
ми скр і так і застряють ось ривочок
божевільному базового доходу не буде
стимулу проти ти про те синій мартін
ян сцени подібно esp одягаєте ще
програматор ватами я програма душем і
не та допомогла джеймс можу проти ти на
повний день
думаю вона так само пішла б на кора з
багатим людям і загалом вуса спірс твоїх
зміните її вас париж на слід продовжить
та екшн xp роман фінляндії з базовим
доходом виявити а успішним і їжа світло
може хлопець а ти і не шукай країни